C'est fait! Après 55 jours de confinement nous voici arrivés à destination,
prêts pour ouvrir les portes et découvrir le monde extérieur.
*inspiration*
Je suis content. Le vaisseau a tenu le coup et vous aussi.
Bon le décor a un peu changé. Souvenez-vous, tout a commencé ici, au pied de ce prunus, il était alors en fleurs.
Aujourd'hui il est couvert de feuilles et porte des fruits.
Je vous en aurais bien montré mais chaque matin il y a un couple pigeon ramier qui vient et prendre son petit déjeuner.
Pendant cette traversée, je vous ai également parlé de mon compost depuis je l'ai utilisé j'ai planté des fraisiers,
du persil,
de la salade,
des betteraves. Promis on fera la récolte ensemble.
J'ai aussi réalisé des jardinières. Vous vous souvenez de la menthe?
Et j'ai semé des tomates qui sont en train de lever. Allez, dans l'atelier maintenant.
Pendant ces 55 jours la terre à tourner, je vous ai parlé de sa vitesse de rotation,
de sa position autour du soleil qui changent au fil des saisons, nous sommes passés de l'hiver au printemps.
Elle a grondé aussi sur l'île de la réunion le volcan est entré en éruption.
La lune a également fait le tour de la terre et elle continue de nous présenter toujours la même face, quel voyage !
Nous avons décollé avec des fusées, nous nous sommes approchés
des nuages, d'un trou noir, des trous dans le fromage et aussi du petit trou percé dans la colonne d'un stylo bille.
Et faute de vous parler du chas de l'aiguille et bien je vous ai présenté Nitro mon petit chat adoré.
Je tenais également à vous adresser un immense merci au début cette aventure et il n'y avait pas de chaîne YouTube.
Vous avez eu raison d'insister.
Avant-hier la barre des 400 mille abonnés a été franchi sur ma chaîne et comme un bonheur n'arrive jamais seul,
vous avez également franchi la barre des 300 mille abonnés sur Twitter et vous êtes désormais plus de 200 mille fans sur Facebook.
Merci pour votre enthousiasme, vos encouragements, votre envie de découvrir le monde, de mêler connaissances et poésie
merci aux scientifiques, aux experts, aux enseignants qui ont bien voulu me donner un petit peu de leur temps pour répondre
à mes questions quand je voulais vérifier ou approfondir tel ou tel point.
Alors rassurez-vous, on ne va pas se quitter.
Pendant ces 55 jours, nous avons beaucoup ri, pas que le 1er avril, on a pleuré aussi, et ça
c'était à cause des oignons. Les liens que nous avons tissés
sont trop forts. Je vais donc continuer à vous faire découvrir les coulisses du monde qui nous entourent.
J'ai plein de belles histoires à vous raconter, de phénomènes à vous expliquer, de sites à vous faire découvrir, de gens à vous faire rencontrer.
Dernière chose,
bravo à la petite caméra et à ses petites mains qui ont fabriqué tous les accessoires que j'ai utilisés
J'allais oublier, les escargots !
Vous aussi vous êtes déconfinés,
et vous avez raison vous avez tout votre temps, il y a tellement de belles choses à découvrir derrière le mur.
Allez, à très vite demain matin nous serons déconfinés mais nous restons en lien. À très bientôt
pour de nouvelles capsules de déconfiné
version "lungo".
Vous pouvez évidemment voir ou revoir toutes celles qui ont été publiés pendant le confinement il vous suffit de cliquer sur la gauche !
Et pour être sûr de ne pas louper les prochaines eh bien... abonnez-vous ! À très bientôt,
et prenez soin de vous.